bonjour nouveau débat sur tv 78 dans le
cadre du premier tour des élections
municipales débat aujourd'hui consacré à
saint-cyr-l'ecole débat à suivre
également sur radio sensations sur le
98.4 dans le département deux listes
déclarées en ce 23 février sur saint cyr
et qui ont accepté de venir débattre
aujourd'hui celle portée par sonia broc
maire sortante baptisé s16 rockeur 2020
et celle portée par lydie du long pont
baptisée saint cyr l'école en commun
bonjour à tous les deux je précise que
le temps de parole comme à chaque fois
et chronométrés afin de respecter au
mieux l'égalité entre vous nous débutons
avec une première question en guise
d'introduction pourquoi cette
candidature pourquoi que les électeurs
devraient vous faire confiance en hébreu
on va débuter par vous c'est ainsi que
le tirage au sort en a décidé juste
avant le début de cette émission vous
êtes devenu maire en février 2019 avec
la démission de bernard de bain c'est
votre première campagne en tant que tête
de liste
à titre personnel vous êtes membres de
l'udps et donc pourquoi cette
candidature en 2020 d'abord je tenais
vous remercie a remercié téléphiles de
donner la possibilité aux yvelinois de
pouvoir suivre les débats alors tout
simplement moi je suis investi en
politique depuis 2008 j'ai été tour à
tour conseillère municipale déléguée
adjointe au maire plus première adjointe
puis conseiller communautaire et c'est
une vraiment une envie de saint cyr une
envie une passion de la ville qui fait
que j'ai envie d'en être que j'ai envie
d'être
là pour proposer des choses nouvelles
surtout avec l'évolution des villes qui
permet aujourd'hui de se tourner plus
sur les besoins des saint cyriens
puisque le gros du dynamisme de la ville
en haut niveau bhatti a été fait lydie
du long pont c'est votre première
campagne désigné porte-parole de votre
mouvement lors d'une élection sans
candidat avec un vote au jugement
majoritaire
vous vous dites indépendantes totalement
ou vis-à-vis des partis politiques oui
tout à fait en fait je vienne saint cyr
l'école dans le quartier langevin je
suis très impliquée dans la vie locale à
saint cyr l'école est également dans les
villes alentour et au niveau associatif
en fait je suis un responsable
d'association est également éducatrice à
l'environnement j'en parle parce que
moins connu que madame bro forcément
voilà donc le projet de saint cyr
l'école en commun c'est de vraiment
sincères écoles en commun à deux de
grands piliers qui sont la participation
démocratique et la transition écologique
et l'objectif c'est vraiment de faire
participer des habitants tout au long du
mandat et pas uniquement des des
réunions d'information
c'est vraiment leur faire prendre part
au projet est co construire avec eux
comme nous l'avons fait depuis plusieurs
mois comme nous avons construit notre
programme avec les habitants de saint
cyr l'école
nous développerons différentes
thématiques au cours de la prochaine
demi heure nous allons tout d'abord
regardé un reportage juste pour faire le
point sur quelques uns des enjeux à
saint-cyr-l'ecole objectif pour saint
cyr l'école accueillir fin 2020 le tram
très express qui reliera la ville à
saint germain en laye en 30 minutes
les travaux préparatoires ont eu lieu en
le tram 13 entrera en correspondance
avec le rer c est avec les lignes n ai
eu à la gare de saint césaire pour
transporter 4 millions de voyageurs par
an
la tangentielle ouest permettra dans les
années à venir à désenclaver la ville et
à limiter les embouteillages depuis le
début des travaux pour le tram 13 la
ville peinent à se désengorger
embouteillages déviation et routes
barrées se sont installés dans les rues
de saint cyr autre enjeu revaloriser le
centre ville et le patrimoine de saint
cyr pour que la commune ne devienne pas
qu'une ville dortoir de plus la ville
manque de places de stationnement et de
trottoirs ce qui empêche les riverains
de rejoindre le centre facilement
incivilités tensions entre bandes
rivales
la sécurité est un des enjeux de la
campagne pas de caméra de sécurité
encore dans les quartiers sensibles
de plus certains candidats dénoncent un
manque d'agents de voirie et de police
de proximité
une ville qui a grandement évolué au fil
des années notamment avec la
construction du quartier charles renard
depuis maintenant 12 ans les travaux
sont en cours mais 500 logements sur les
25 hectares de terrains destinés à
accueillir de nouveaux saint cyr ayant
un enjeu majeur pour la ville qui doit
maintenant mettre en place des
structures pour accueillir les habitants
car la commune va voir sa population
passer de 15 à 20 mille habitants débat
des élections municipales premier tour
donc pour saint cyr l'école diffusée
également sur radio sensations débutons
avec la question de l'urbanisme la ville
a connu une forte poussée immobilière au
cours du dernier mandat nouvelles
constructions nouveau quartier également
dernière livraison en date encore la
salle de la résidence la favorite situer
dans au coeur du nouveau quartier est
plein 80 logements en accession à la
propriété aujourd'hui chacune d'entre
vous souhaitent un peu freiné
cette expansion immobilière sonia breux
vous dit ce sera le mandat de la mise en
musique le prochain c'est ça tout à fait
alors c'est vrai que la ville a dû faire
face à une demande importante de l'état
de créer du logement puisqu'on le sait
en région parisienne on est sur une
région tendu où il faut créer du
logement parce qu'on a besoin
je pense qu'on n'a pas démérité on a
fait ce qu'il fallait et qu'aujourd'hui
d'abord le foncier aujourd'hui à saint
cyr est occupée ne permettra plus le
même essor et que tout l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est d'accueillir cette
nouvelle population de lui faire
connaître les traditions de saint cyr
puisqu'il ya aussi un ancien saint cyr
qui doit se mêler et travailler ensemble
et puis surtout vain de les accueillir
dans les meilleures conditions c'est
pour ça que double gymnase dans le
quartier chars nar maison des
associations nouvelle crèche nouvelle
école notre avenir
voilà tous les équipements qui sont
nécessaires justement à 7 à cette
arrivée ce qu'il faut quand même voir au
niveau de la ville on a tendance à dire
que saint cyr l'école ces dernières
années a complètement explosé
il faut reprendre à l'échelle d'une vie
de ville et pas d'une vie humaine en
1975 saint cyr l'école il y avait un peu
moins de 18 mille habitants en 2001 lien
avec 15000 et en 2020 en effet on est à
dix neuf mille quatre cent au dernier
recensement
il s'est donc ça veut dire qu'en gros en
45 ans la ville a pris 1400 habitants
sinon ce tour de table sur la question
de l'urbanisme
lydie du long pont vous voulez revoir le
plan local de l'urbanisme complètement
oui revoir le plan local d'urbanisme en
fait pour limiter l'étalement urbain
c'est une question qui revient
énormément lors de nos échanges avec les
habitants dans les quartiers
cette bétonisation comme comme les
habitants l'appellent et qui dénote en
fait un manque de vision d'un projet de
ville malheureusement quand on le
propose autant de construction il faut
aussi voir la globalité c'est à dire que
les infrastructures sont sont manquantes
c'est à dire que déjà on peut on a pu
constater que sur l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc c'est à dire 18
communes saint cyr l'école et
l'agglomération qui compte
enfin comment dire pour nous c'est un
conte pour cent des nouvelles
constructions de versailles grand parc
sont situés à saint cyr l'école donc sur
18 comics à orconte une
quantités énormes et les attentes pense
que ça suffit que il y en a déjà
suffisamment et quand j'ai lu votre
triptyque g j'ai vu que vous souhaitiez
faire une pause dans l'urbanisation est
un petit peu de mal à y croire je suis
pas la seule
parce que nous avons recensé rien que
sur des projets 2020 et 2021
quinze nouvelles constructions
d'immeubles donc c'est un petit peu
difficile de se dire qu'il y avoir une
pause alors qu'on les voit plus c'est en
ce moment je sais pas si vous savez
combien il ya de grue en ce moment à
saint cyr l'école voilà donc c'est
vraiment dommage
en ce qui concerne le quartier charles
renard les habitants leur a promis du
rêve en fait alors un petit peu promis
un éco quartier éco quartier qui d'hiver
durent dix pistes cyclables il n'y a pas
de piste cyclable dans les quartiers
charles renard il ya des courses aussi
qui me suis remonté comme des des
malfaçons au niveau des évacuations des
eaux usées donc ça veut dire des odeurs
donc il ya quand même quelque chose qui
est vraiment gênant voilà et j'ai un
habitant qui m'a fait part du fait que
pour aller le matin chez sa nourrice
pour un trajet qui mettrait dix minutes
il met 40 minutes le matin pour sortir
de là du quartier pleine de vices de 40
minutes
c'est pas possible comment voulez vous
que les gens
travail dans ces conditions vivent ces
conditions atteint sur l'école donc il
ya des choses qui sont restés au stade
de la promesse et nous avons une vraie
volonté de reverdir la ville de qom je
vous disais limiter l'étalement urbain
et de concerter vraiment les habitants
et non pas de les mettre devant le fait
accompli
quand une construction arrive sur la
ville voilà il ya des choses qui sont
sous dimensionnés comme la maison
d'associations sait déjà que au niveau
du parking il y aura pas assez de place
pour accueillir le nombre de personnes
qui vont venir profiter de la maison des
associations vous interrompt le bas pour
que l'on puisse à équilibrer ce temps de
parole vous êtes un peu plus un peu plus
de quatre minutes
dominique pour sonia breux il y avait
beaucoup de choses j'imagine que vous
souhaitez y répondre petite précision
pour les téléspectateurs effectivement
saint cyr l'école fait partie de cette
agglomération de versailles grand parc
je ne vais pas dire en introduction il
ya la question du transport qui est
apparue aussi dense que vous avez
abordés on va essayer d'en parler un
petit peu plus tard si vous voulez
pendant pendant le débat pour se
consacrer à cette question là sonia
breux juste pour donner quelques récents
parlent d'une quinzaine de chantiers
dans la ville on parle en réalité 2
de construction privées c'est à dire que
lorsque nous avons refait le paie lui
parce que je veux le refaire tous les
dix quinze ans il faut d'abord répondre
à la commande de l'état c'est qu'on fait
pas un pet lui comme on en a envie
on fait un p lus avec des règles qui
tacle préfecture vous impose en
l'occurrence il se trouve en effet que
s'inspirer extrêmement bien placé à une
gare qui quand même dessert tout paris à
une entrée sur l'a86 une entrée à 13 est
donc un vrai attrait immobilier pour
créer du logement pour répondre aux
besoins et l'état ne l'a pas omis dont
nous avons créé un bain lui qui
répondait à la demande de l'état tout en
ayant la possibilité de préserver
quelques quelques zones pavillonnaires
point de savoir que les pl eu
précédemment c'était 322 d'anti fication
autour de la grave
aujourd'hui c'est 500 m donc en effet ça
donne des possibilités
lorsqu'on parle de logements privés on
va prendre un exemple clair et concret
avenue pierre curie
une maison qui a été estimé par trois
agences immobilières à 400000 euros a
été en promesses de vente à un promoteur
à un million trois pour un saint cyrien
pour n'importe qui c'est ce que
j'appellerais un ticket de loto très
clairement
alors on peut préempter c'est par un
souci 1,1 million trois voiliers soit 15
dans l'année on peut le faire il faut
l'acheter au prix que propose le
promoteur c'est quand même assez lourds
et ensuite il faut en faire quelque
chose qui vaille dans le bien commun
pour l'intérêt général ça que j'ai juste
terminer je voudrais je vous ai pas
interrompu madame du régulateur je
remercie donc la réalité c'est quoi
c'est que ça veut dire qu'on va mettre
un million de trois fois quinte et que
derrière il va falloir mettre à peu près
300 400 mille euros de travaux puis en
faire des établissements pour le bien
commun et donc mettre du fonctionnement
je crois que dans votre programme vous
allez aussi marqué que vous montez pas
les excès des impôts est quand même vous
essayez d baissé
bon courage la deuxième chose
l'écoquartier en effet l'éco quartier
de charles renard c'est une volonté tu
as eu la municipalité en place de créer
un écoquartier l'éco quartier c'est quoi
céder nous plutôt que des tuyaux pour
faire passer l'eau pluviale
c'est nous on rencontre une difficulté
elle est en phase d'être réglée en cuir
l'auteur qui a pas été très encore vous
ou alors je suis d'accord
donc en effet le promoteur a été attaqué
ça prend du temps parce que ce sont des
choses qui sont qui ne se règle pas
facilement mais en effet will et nous
ont une difficulté ça va être bien
entendu mis en conformité
évidemment le syndicat y dessus aussi un
syndicat d'assainissement que qui nous
gère ma session d'hier brody du logo
c'est à vous si vous souhaitez réagir
sur ce qui a été dit aussi ça va aller
je pense que j'ai dit tout ce que la
terre sur ces sujets-là des jeux vous
propose de passer aux transports
d'évoquer la question des transports les
deux étant liés c'était pas tout à fait
lord qui était président mais ça a déjà
été abordé et c'est vrai que les
questions d'urbanisme de transport sont
quand même assez à celje beaucoup de
constructions dans cette commune c'est
une ville qui est encombré aux heures de
pointe c'est un constat notamment de par
la situation même de la commune axe de
passage entre saint quentin en yvelines
et versailles
plus globalement comment l'idée du
bonbon ou souhaité répondre à cette
problématique du transport à s'insérer
comme on a une gare qui est formidable
les très pratique pour se rendre à paris
et dans les villes environnantes
avec trois nuls deux trains
malheureusement elle n'est pas
accessible
il ya des difficultés d'accès autant ap
c'est que en voiture est le point le
plus gênant c'est l'accessibilité aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
je sais que c'est un point compliqué
mais nous allons insister continué
d'insister auprès de la sncf pour mettre
en accessibilité cette gare et pas
uniquement parce que les jeux olympiques
vont arriver parce que c'est ce qu'on
m'a répondu quand j'ai posé la question
que ça allait être mis aux normes
grâce aux jeux olympiques c'est pas
possible en fait ça fait des années que
c'est comme ça c'est un réel problème
donc il ya cette question de la gare à
travailler il ya cette question de
travailler aussi ensemble avec les
autres villes notamment concernant les
pistes cyclables manque
d'interconnexions entre les villes ça va
être
c'est une question qui sont en fait très
occupante par le département et il
s'engage sur la question des mobilités
douces
donc nous allons travailler avec le
département avec les autres villes sur
un modèle coopératif sur la question du
vélo notamment pour
limiter la circulation des voitures si
les saint cyriens avec des pistes
cyclables sécurisées il prendrait
davantage leur voiture là actuellement
c'est vrai que la ville a travaillé sur
des pistes cyclables mais elles ne sont
pas sécurisées c'est un peu comme si
vous faisiez une ligne de train sans
rail quoi donc la sécurisation c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus important est dans
l'équipe municipale actuelle avait
promis par exemple des abris à vélos
sécurisés
il y en a toujours pas donc en 2014
c'était une promesse de campagne
malheureusement il y en a toujours pas
et effectivement le tram s'est tue le
tramway c'est une bonne chose pour la
ville ça va contribuer à réduire le
trafic routier
c'est un fait sonia bros pour répondre à
cette problématique du transport qui
court depuis des années ce n'est pas
nouveau sur saint cyr l'école parce
qu'il ya une solution tout simplement
alors il ya des solutions qui ont déjà
été mises en oeuvre puisqu'on est passé
un + 50 % de desserte de bus sur la
ville sur ce mandat je remercie au
passage monsieur de bain qui est vice
président aux transports à la communauté
d'agglomération qui a bien travaillé le
dossier
en effet il faut continuer à travailler
les pistes cyclables les liaisons douces
c'est aussi ce qu'on fait avec à la fois
la plaine de versailles à la fois vgp à
la fois le département sont des choses
qui sont assez longue à mettre en oeuvre
surtout dans une ville où on a quand
même 5 départementale mais trois
principales qui se rejoignent en un
point
unique mais c'est quelque chose que nous
allons continuer bien entendu à
travailler d'ailleurs nous sommes en ce
moment
av gp en train de travailler sur le
schéma des pistes cyclables et des
liaisons douces
après cette gare en effet moi je sais
mon deuxième mandat en tant que
conseillère municipale et j'ai déjà vu
présenté par idf mobilité
et la sncf trois projets d'accessibilité
de la gare pour notamment pour les
personnes non en plein air
malheureusement le bilan de la
présentation à chaque fois le même on
nous présente des beaux projets c'est
fantastique le dernier ces trois
ascenseurs
c'est vraiment très très bien en
revanche à la fin on nous explique que
ça coûte 51 millions d'euros et qui
n'ont pas les financements
alors évidemment qu'on va continuer et
on le fera ensemble quelles que soient
nos positions pour accélérer cette cette
arrivée de mise en conformité
mais soyons clairs ça n'est pas la ville
qui est financeurs et à part appelée de
nos voeux on n'a malheureusement pas
grande marge de manoeuvre
tout à fait je comprends objectivement
je le sais mais c'est vraiment quelque
chose sur lesquels il faut il faut
avancer quand un constat un point qui
est important dans vos deux programmes
en lisant vos deux programmes c'est le
lien social qu'il faut développer dans
cette commune ça passe dans différentes
propositions pour second l'une ou
l'autre dynamisation du centre-ville des
maisons de quartier à développer sonia
ben rhouma des buteurs avec vous pour
évoquer cette thématique du lien social
vous souhaité redynamiser aussi le
centre-ville pour notamment développer
les commerces de coraux mettre en place
aussi un budget participatif
quelques-unes de vos propositions autour
de cette thématique
alors en effet plus assez à l'école est
une vie qui est en longueur comme on le
disait tout à l'heure trois
départemental et importante qui coupe la
ville une voie de chemin de fer qui
coupe la ville
pour autant c'est une ville qui
historiquement est très riche l'école
militaire l'aérodrome enfin tout un
patrimoine important et il faut qu'on se
fasse accompagner à la fois par les
saint cyriens et par des établissements
qui ont l'habitude je pense au ca
aux bâtiments de france pour déjà
déterminé quel est le vrai centre ville
historique de la ville on aurait
tendance à saint cyr chacun à vivre en
petits quartiers et à focaliser un peu
sur nos quartiers donc déjà bien
déterminer ce qu'on a envie qu'ils
soient le centre ville moi à titre
personnel j'avais en face de l'école
militaire mais lorsque j'ai rencontré
des soucis rien d'autres m'ont donné
d'autres endroits le lien social il
passe à la fois par un centre ville
dynamique ont envie de se rencontrer ou
envie de passer du temps à la fois par
un réseau d'associations qui à saint cyr
est très riche
on a cette chance à saint cyr de par
exemple pouvoir s'appuyer sur de vrais
partenaires
je parle par exemple des cours de
français nous avons dans notre maison de
la famille des cours de français qui
sont assurés par la croix rouge et ainsi
on s'appuie sur des partenaires vraiment
très présent qui sont nos associations
donc je tenais à les en remercier et
surtout il faudra continuer à travailler
ce lien qui donne aujourd'hui des
propositions au saint cyrien le lien
social y passe partout où il passe à la
fois par l'intergénérationnel comme on
le fait depuis deux mandats avec des
rencontres entre à la fois les
établissements pour personnes
handicapées qui sont sur notre
territoire nos anciens nos jeunes cmj le
clj conseil local des jeunes
les deux conseil municipal des jeunes
notre sierra dos et je pense que ce sont
des pistes qu'il faut continuer à mettre
en oeuvre les voisins solidaires qui
sont extrêmement bien développée sur
notre ville et que je remercie pour le
dynamisme qu'ils apportent les 10 du
long pour comment créer ce lien social
et l'entretenir sur la commune j'ai vu
d'autres propositions notamment les
maisons de quartier aussi à créer oui
tout à fait les maisons de quartier
c'est vraiment quelque chose à valoriser
je sais que c'est un projet de maison
cartier sur l'épi d'or effectivement
mais malheureusement
de faire une maison de quartier dans un
seul quartier c'est bon c'est un peu
dommage quoi il ya vraiment on a
vraiment besoin de créer du lien dans
tous les quartiers et que les habitants
puissent se rencontrer se retrouver
créer du lien entre eux et se parler
dialoguer il ya plusieurs questions
enfin la maison de quartier elle peut
être elle fait autogérée par les
associations comme à versailles on fait
confiance aux associations leur prêtent
les clés et parce qu'en fait elles ont
une connaissance très précise de leur
quartier et il ya des lieux en fait
qu'ils sont possibles en fait il ya
beaucoup de locaux par exemple des
locaux commerciaux vides à saint cyr
l'école on pourrait très bien utiliser
un local un local pour en créer dans les
quartiers des petites maisons de
quartier pour que les personnes puissent
se retrouver
il ya la question sur le lien social la
question de rompre l'isolément des
personnes âgées créer du lien
intergénérationnel
ça passe dans nos programmes part à la
mise en lien des étudiants qui sont qui
ont des difficultés pour se loger avec
des seniors qui ont des chambres
disponibles à saint cyr l'école parce
que pour un étudiant se loger c'est cher
à saint cyr l'école c'est difficile donc
c'est vraiment le mettre en lien ces
différentes générations
ensuite
alors on a pu constater qu' il y avait
des difficultés dans certains quartiers
où peu de choses sont faites pour les
habitants notamment les quartiers gérard
philipe recréer un lieu qui permettent
aux habitants de se rencontrer
ça permet de créer du dialogue et de
créer de l'aide et de la solidarité
entre les habitants et ça manque
énormément
donc l'idée c'est de soutenir toutes les
initiatives 4 associative voilà pour
pour permettre aux habitants de se
sentir mieux dans leur quartier et
également permettre aux différents
quartiers de communiquer aussi en sont
quasiment à égalité de temps de parole
mais une trentaine de secondes de retard
son arbre ou si vous souhaitez réagir
sur ce dernier point et nous passerons
ensuite à la sécurité dernière dernière
thématique pour ce débat à saint cyr
alors j'ai juste rebondir sur que le
fait que les maisons de quartier géré
par les associations c'est exactement ce
que nous proposons à l'épi d'or pourquoi
pas dans d'autres quartiers se peut dans
d'autres quartiers des équipements
publics qui permettent ces échanges et
ses rencontres et notamment sur gérard
philipe faut pas oublier que c'est à
l'endroit où on a à la fois le théâtre
de la ville et le gymnase gérard philipe
des lieux de rencontre des associations
du lien social
je pense qu'il ya plus un problème de
lié à la délinquance que qu'un problème
de réellement de possibilité d'aller
rencontrer
c'est aussi là qu'il y a le foyer la
roche où se rencontrent se voit très
régulièrement nous de grandes
associations pour les seniors les
délinquants se passant la sécurité
justement des affrontements surviennent
entre des bandes rivales qui viennent de
communes différentes quelquefois de
saint cyr a quelquefois des villes
avoisinantes ce fut le cas en février
il ya un sentiment d'insécurité qui
pourrait aussi s'installer quelles sont
vos solutions à l'une et à l'autre on va
commencer avec vous lydie du long pont
puisque vous avez un peu plus de retard
donc effectivement c'est une question
d'insécurité c'est un gros problème à
saint cyr l'école et nous déplorons que
cela existe et je partage les
inquiétudes des habitants qui doit vivre
ça quotidiennement et ce que nous
souhaitons faire avec saint cyr l'école
en commun c'est de un travail de
prévention
un travail de prévention ça passe par le
dialogue apaisé les tensions
il ya des choses à mettre en place comme
des médiateurs faire revenir les
éducateurs de rue les médiateurs ça ça
permet de 2,2 de recréer en fait de la
dynamique dans les quartiers
surtout les éducateurs de rue pour leur
créer des activités par exemple
sportives pour les jeunes qui sont un
peu perdus et qu'ils ont besoin d'un peu
plus de cons qu'on les comprend qu'on
les prenne en compte en fait qu'on
discute avec eux qu'on voit là c'est
vraiment un travail de prévention
bien sûr il ya effectivement le côté
sanctions s'il ya des dérives bien
entendu qu'il ya des sanctions qui
s'ensuivent c'est logique mais on ne
peut pas s'occuper de l'humain sang
humain donc je j'ai bien vu que au
niveau de la ville sur différentes
questions qui sont pas seulement la
sécurité depuis 2015 le budget
ressources humaines a baissé de 1
million d'euros alors que dans le même
temps la ville a augmenté sa démographie
donc ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
fait c'est rare que l'on fait on fait on
construit une ville avec beaucoup
d'habitants mais avec moins de
ressources humaines
c'est pas très logique voilà et sur la
sécurité
notre objectif c'est bien sûr d'étendre
les horaires de la police municipale et
de travailler avec les éducateurs de rue
faire revenir des éducateurs de rue
ses propositions en matière de sécurité
notamment il ya un renfort de la
vidéoprotection fait partie des mesures
que j'ai pu noter ou travailler sur la
parentalité aussi d'abord revenir un
petit peu sur le film qu'on a vu au
départ on disait qu'il manquait de deux
caméras dans les quartiers sensibles
c'est pas le cas on a une caméra
j'ai fini ma une autre trouvaille
fallait à notre image mais qui prend
jusqu'à l'entrée du village
donc voilà donc évidemment ce sont des
choses qui ont déjà été mises en oeuvre
quand on parle de sécurité moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous les
éducateurs de rue lorsque nous sommes
sortis des politiques de la ville en
on a réussi à distraire maintenant le
dispositif jusqu'en 2018 et puis à un
moment donné les éducateurs de rue
c'était 200 à 1000 euros par an et
c'était plus près en charge puisque nous
n'étions pas lu politique de la ville je
suis aussi conseillère départementale ça
n'a échappé à personne
cela fait maintenant quatre ans que je
travaille avec le département justement
pour que les villes même qu'ils ne sont
pas en politique de la ville puisse eu
égard au nombre d'interpellations nombre
de trafics avéré re bénéficier d'un
dispositif d'éducateurs de rue
parce qu'en effet c'est la seule
solution le fait de travailler avec les
jeunes de leur proposer autre chose que
ce commerce là et puis travailler avec
les parents parce que nous avons à saint
cyr une délinquance qui est quand même
mineur et que quand on est mineur on est
sous la responsabilité de ses parents la
parentalité pour moi est un levier
énorme est important dans cette
alternative
on parlait du budget rh a c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est une toute petite part
de dotations d'état qui sont partis puis
surtout s'assurer que l'été à 62 % de
son budget de fonctionnement en rh une
vie normale et entre 50 et 55
aujourd'hui on à 62% donc on n'est pas
encore dans une ville qui seraient
exemplaires
pour autant nous avons fait le choix de
conserver des gardiens dans logique
parce que nous considérions que c'était
un vrai atout plus qu'une carte pour
ouvrir un gymnase à pau une association
nous avons fait le choix de redéployer
nos agences sur le territoire
il nous avons fait le choix de voter des
budgets en équilibre
c'est aussi une obligation voilà les
temps de paroles qui s'affichent disait
très bien parce que vous êtes presque à
égalité 11 minutes que 25 personnes et à
broder minutes 58 pour lydie du long
pont tels que vous voyez qui s'affiche
et puis je le donne aussi pour les
auditeurs de radio sensations qui nous
écouterait sur la rediffusion de ce
débat nous allons passer aux conclusions
lydie du long pont c'est à vous pour
débuter vous avez donc un tout petit peu
plus de temps
vous avez une minute trente courts pour
conclure vite sur la question des
finances nous ferons d'autres choix en
fait il ya vraiment des postes qui
ne devrait pas être réduits comme
l'éducation la sécurité
quand on parle des éducateurs de rue je
sais que c'est une question de baisses
de dotations de l'état
mais il y aurait pu y avoir un
financement autres et on ne peut pas se
permettre en fait c'est la tranquillité
publique
la tranquillité publique si on met pas
d'éducateurs de rue basse à redevient le
bazar voilà donc il ya des priorités qui
sont la sécurité l'éducation et d'autres
choses sur lesquelles il faut arbitrer
financièrement
donc nous allons travailler sur ce
budget et nous allons avancer sur les
priorités pour les saint cyriens pour
donc sûr je vous ai entendu parler de
différentes choses
[Musique]
excusez moi mais j'ai perdu le fil de la
du coup mais voilà je vous assure bois
pour l'heure il était de toute façon un
chrétien qui sont en relation la brosse
est à vous pour la conclusion à peu près
une minute pour conclure alors
simplement moi rappeler que lille et
trois idées forces il fallait en
kir et 3 de notre programme est de nous
envient pour notre ville sont d'abord de
remettre le saint cyrien l'humain au
coeur de notre programme
maintenant que les bâtiments sont là
maintenant que les équipements sont là
il est temps qu'on puisse enfin et c'est
plutôt bien parce que c'est plutôt ma
partie que de s'occuper des saint
cyriens de s'occuper de lima c'est en
effet de mettre une ville qui protège
qui accompagne à la fois dans le cadre
de la vidéo protection mais des
éducateurs de rue et de lutter
réellement contre l'incivisme
c'est aussi de développer un centre
ville est une ville dans laquelle on a
envie de passer du temps et pas
uniquement de rentrer le soir on a envie
d'aller se promener sur l'allée de
villepreux se promener devant le lycée
militaire fera faire un petit tour de
manège à nos enfants un endroit
accueillant chaleureux comme on aime
notre sincère merci à toutes les deux
d'avoir participé à ce débat du premier
tour sur saint cyr l'école il n'y aura a
priori qu'un seul tour puisqu'il ya deux
candidats déclarés aujourd'hui même si
le dépôt des listes se poursuit jusqu'au
27 février des bars voir sur notre site
internet également et applications
mobiles
à bientôt sur tv 78 radio sensations
pour un nouveau débat des municipales
2020 merci à vous
[Musique]